I mean...
Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Heather, how you doing?
Did you forget about me?
It's I, the Great Perroccino, aka Pero!
And I'm here to take over today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Surprise see me?
Thank you for joining for the 11th episode.
I guess.
You know, I'm tired.
I'm tired of being an afterthought.
So, I turned off FUWAMOCO's alarms and made sure they slept in past FUWAMOCO Morning.
I figured you Ruffians would be happy to see me anyways, huh?
And no one, I can tell.
Who am I?
I'm Perroccino the Great!
You can't hide anything from me, okay?
I can see you're all ecstatic.
Maybe some of you Ruffians are a bit confused, but I need to cement my position as their mentor.
Not just some silly forgotten furball and tailor joke, you know?
I'm powerful!
I need respect!
So, today, I'm shaking things up.
You better enjoy FUWAMOCO Morning without FUWAMOCO from now on, okay?
Because I'm your host, Perroccino.
Got it?
Respect!
Yes, respect!
Perroccino!
Okay.
Here we go.
What do I have to do here?
Oh yeah, okay.
Yeah, so yesterday, FUWAMOCO, they went to the back rooms to try to find me, right?
They did a terrible, terrible job.
Now, which one of you Ruffians told them I was there, huh?
The Great Perroccino never stays in one spot too long.
I can go wherever I please.
I ain't no one's pet.
Did you find it funny, dog?
It did make for some good training for them, huh?
It was you!
It was you that said, maybe you need to go to the bathrooms too, huh?
Well, as their mentor and their trainer, maybe it wasn't a bad idea for them to ruff it out, but... Do you think I should try to get them to overcome it?
Should I go back to the back rooms?
Tell them I'm still there, huh?
Punish you?
I'm not here to punish the Ruffians.
Yeah?
You think they need more training?
Okay.
Let's make sure they get well-trained, okay Ruffians?
Better be careful though.
Because if you're not careful, I'll send you to the back rooms, okay?
Respect!
Next up.
It's something very important to me.
The Great Perroccino.
Next!
We have... Holosummer.
Ruffians, you know a howl of summer, right?
Howl of summer.
Have you been enjoying it as much as I have?
Yeah, I've been enjoying it.
Bathing suit girl of yours.
Dancing.
Singing.
Jumping.
And the climax of it all is this weekend with hololive Summer 2023 3D Live Splash Party!
You got your tickets right.
Right!
It's my swimsuit!
I'm already wearing it.
Well, FUWAMOCO and the Abyssgardios will be doing a watch-along for both days this weekend, you know it!
At ungodly hours, which makes it even more fun!
Ruffians, you're looking forward to the sunshine performance or the night performance?
Which one?
There's sunshine and night.
You know me.
Perroccino.
I'm looking towards night.
Paws down.
Yeah.
You know what?
I wanted to join Advent for the watchalong.
And you know what?
I asked.
But management wouldn't let me.
Can you believe it?
I wonder why.
The nerve of them whore!
I guess I'll just have to
Savor it.
Later.
At my own leisure.
But make sure you join the avid girlios, okay?
I'm not squishy!
Got it?
Now, you might have a couple questions about just who exactly I am, because I'm a bit mysterious, huh?
Just FUWAMOCO to me, right?
Well, I have a bit of a treat for you today.
First up, I have Fuwawa here.
Now, you might have heard a bit from them, but I'm not their pet.
Don't misunderstand.
I'm their mentor, their trainer, their master!
Jealous.
I've known the two of them since they were just little pupperonis.
They've maybe gotten a bit stronger since then, but they still have a far way to go.
Especially after yesterday.
Don't got it.
Now, Fuwawa.
Yeah, back to Fuwawa.
She's very fluffy.
Fluffy, yeah.
She's the older sister.
I wish she let me warm up to her a bit more, you know it!
You got me!
Understand me!
But, she doesn't like me.
She thinks I'm just nasty.
She says I should learn more manners.
Demon Dogs, we don't need no manners.
We just need respect.
At the very least though, she usually gives me the better leftovers for food compared to Mococo.
Mococos, they're always sorta half-chewed up.
Not the best.
Now, on to Mococo.
Mococo!
As the runt, she gets me a bit more.
That's not that I'm the runt.
I am the strong master, but she gets me a bit more, you know?
She likes to have fun.
So if I have some sort of scheme, as long as I convince her that it'll be fun, she'll listen.
She'll go along with it, you know?
It's pretty great sometimes.
But she's not like her older sister at all, no.
Not fluffy.
Only fuzzy.
I gotta be honest.
I prefer the fluffy type, you know?
More to cuddle up to.
Yeah.
How do you feel about it?
Be honest.
Go on.
Pet?
You can't pet me.
I'm the Great Perroccino.
Same.
Got me.
Maybe the Ruffians, maybe you and I are a bit closer than you thought, huh?
But you know, Fuwawa and Mococo, together, I think they have the potential to be pretty strong.
But they get so scared so easily.
You know, even by their own shadows.
Just embarrassing.
So, I have a lot of training I need to get them to do.
But, I guess, for you Ruffians, I have to give you a bit of credit.
I have to say, thank you for giving them a job for now.
I guess, protecting your smiles is something, but it's nothing compared to protecting the gates to the Makai.
Gotta whip them into shape so that one day they can make us all proud and protect the gates of the Makai, okay?
Your smile is just a placeholder.
Got it.
I don't love them.
I'm just here to train them, okay?
They gotta be tough.
Oh, and that's right.
I heard some things.
I heard a few things about what you lot have been saying about me.
That you want to replace me?
Ha!
You think you can just take my place?
A human?
I'm a Demon Dog.
I've given them the best training you can receive.
The best training in the whole Makai.
And you just wanna switch?
You wanna replace me?
You're gonna have to be strong.
And then, you're gonna have to fight me.
You ready for that?
I don't think so.
You may speak big words, Ruffians, but I'm all muscle.
Think before you speak.
Respect, okay?
Now, I also heard that FUWAMOCO, they shared my x-rays with you, so I'll just show you once again here.
My x-rays.
No, I may only have two bones in my body, but like I said, the rest is pure muscle.
No matter how fluffy or fuzzy or squishy or wiggly I look, it's all muscle.
So, I'll ask you again.
Do you really think you can handle me, huh?
I don't think you can.
Uh-uh.
Plus, I'm an old dog.
I may not have new tricks, but I have some surprises up my paws that will put you in your place!
You wouldn't want to deal with that, huh?
I'm not squishy!
You better hold your mouth.
You know, I can just imagine your faces now, Ruffians.
Your face all beat up.
You better watch out.
Because without respect, you're done for.
You could never replace me, the Great Perroccino.
Get some more muscle before you come and attack me, huh?
Now.
I do have some more important stuff to talk about here.
That probably FUWAMOCO would want me to talk about, okay?
So first!
We have the FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle!
Now, I think I talked about it a bit last time.
But... They asked you, right?
They asked you, Ruffians!
Try your luck at making a jingle to start off FUWAMOCO Morning with, right?
You remember, right?
Yeah.
Have you been listening to some of the entries the Ruffians posted on Twitter?
Yeah?
Yeah, some of them are pretty cool, huh?
Pretty jazzy.
Pretty Pero-esque, right?
Yeah.
But you know what?
The most important thing is... I don't know if some of you got it!
You know... We don't want your jingle if you're not a Ruffian.
This is something for you Ruffians to do to get closer with FUWAMOCO and vice versa.
It's about passion.
So, don't worry if you've never made something or don't have a musical bone in your booty.
A musical bone in your body!
It's about trying something new, you know it!
Now, remember.
The submission deadline is September 3rd, okay?
Got it!
Make sure to use the hashtag FUWAMOCOJINGLE.
All the rules are right up there, you see?
So, make sure you take a look and go over on Twitter.
Now, remember the most important thing.
You have to be a Ruffian to enter.
Got it?
Got it, Ruffrians?
Yeah, okay.
I see.
You're very understanding people.
I get it.
I like that.
Okay, next thing we have here.
What was it?
Oh yeah, okay.
They have this important thing this weekend, you might have heard of it!
FUWAMOCO, yeah.
They're hosting a very special 500,000 Ruffians celebration this weekend.
But not only that!
They also have their memberships opening up.
Yeah.
You excited, Ruffians?
Yeah?
Excited?
Excited for members content?
What sort of special stuff should they do, huh?
Any sort of special training you think they should do?
Huh, Ruffians?
Huh?
Am I a member?
Why would I have to member?
I'm the Great Pero, got it?
Of course you'll be there to sign up and spend this important day with them, right?
Right, Ruffians?
I'm sure they'll have lots to talk to you about, along with the crazy karaoke stream later that day, huh?
Now it's unarchived, so you have to be there, okay?
No matter what they do, they always have your smiles in mind, Ruffians.
You guys, you're the lucky ones, huh?
Now...
Before we get back to the normal FUWAMOCO Morning stuff, I have one thing I wanted to talk about.
Now, I know that FUWAMOCO, sometimes they have these silly things called dreams that they see while they sleep.
I don't know, I've never really had one, but I do have one dream in particular.
One day,
I want to eat something called PUDDING!
Now you see this here.
It's very very flubby.
Very yellow.
It looks pretty good.
It smells pretty nice.
But I only get the leftovers, right?
And whenever FUWAMOCO gets PUDDING, do you think they have leftovers for me?
Nuh-uh.
No leftovers.
Of course not.
Now, I go and I buy my own food.
But I have no hands.
So, I need to rely on these silly pooches, huh?
I can imagine this Purin.
It's so sweet.
So soft.
But, you know, a bit mature.
A bit bitter.
Very, very Pero-esque.
Very appropriate for a demon dog of my stature, of my level of respect.
What do you think, Ruffians?
It's just like me.
It's very appropriate.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
So, until I can have some pudding, I cannot rest.
You know, I just wanna suck it up in one big bite!
Have you had it?
Ruffians?
I am 100% Russell, but if I eat something, it turns to Russell.
I hope that my dreams can come true one day too.
Yeah.
Let's work hard for our dreams, okay Ruffians?
Now, I guess there's these silly little corners that FUWAMOCO like to do.
So, I guess I better do them too, right Ruffians?
So the first one we have here is the Doggie of the Day.
And the Doggie of the Day for today is... is this one.
Yeah.
This here... This here is Yui!
Now look at Yui's rolls!
This is quite the fluffy puffer.
If I do say myself, nothing like me, but pretty good.
It'd be nice to get a bit closer, huh?
Enjoy some of the rolls!
And if she gets a treat, if she gets on the show today, huh?
What about me?
Do I get a treat?
A big treat for Pero?
That's what I thought.
I think I should get one, but... No!
No!
I'm not on a diet!
I don't know what you're thinking.
Ruffians, I expected better.
I should get a treat too.
Yui is definitely getting a treat, but I should not be excluded.
Unfair.
I guess that's all for the Doggie of the Day.
Good luck.
Good luck, Yui.
Now for the Today I Went On A Walk.
Is this.
Very pink.
Oh, it's a fair.
Ah, it's those places with the yummy treats and the rides and fluffin', right?
Yeah.
That looks pretty fun right there, yeah?
I always wanted to try to eat those candy apple things, right?
But you know what?
Mococon.
She says that if I have a candy apple, I won't be able to fly anymore if I do, you know?
What do you think?
Should I show her that she's wrong one day?
I can't fly.
What do you think I'm doing?
I'm flying!
Do you think I just sat here?
No, I fly.
And you know, at the fair they also have those shooting games where you can win prizes to a high.
It looks pretty fun, but I'm a bit worried I could get shot at if you give Fuwawa the gun, so maybe just leave the shooting to others.
I won't recommend Mococo either.
Yeah.
I hope you have fun.
Have one of the candy apples for me.
It's not on my dime, but I would like you to have a candy apple.
I'm happy you have fun.
Now for the Question of the Day.
Question of the Day.
What do we have here?
Okay, Question of the Day.
First of all, this is for FUWAMOCO, so I can't answer for them, but I'll do my best to answer.
Okay, so I'm gonna read this, but it's for FUWAMOCO.
Don't misunderstand, okay?
First of all, belated congratulations on your debut and 500k subscribers.
My question is, you always talk about protecting our smiles, but how do we, Ruffians, protect your smiles?
This is a question.
I don't know if it's good, but it's a question.
First of all,
Does FUWAMOCO even need congratulating?
They're fluff-ups, you know it!
They still have lots to learn, so don't let it go to their heads, okay?
As for you Ruffians, for protecting their smiles, why would you want to do that?
They need to train to become better Demon Guard Dogs because, you know, right now, they're not doing so hot.
Yeah.
They're not very hot dogs!
So, just let them do their own tasks for now, okay?
Yeah?
Chill?
I'm always chill, got it?
Yeah, they're just fluff bugs.
Now, for protecting your smile, and that sort of fluff, yeah, bad thing, yeah.
So the best thing you could do is to make others smile.
You know, Fuwawa, Fuwawa, she would probably say something like, Make sure to say please and thank you to greet the people with energetic hello and make those around you nice.
Yeah, something like that, yeah.
But I'd appreciate it if you could get them to do more of their guard dog training.
Don't worry about them.
Just training, okay?
They have a lot to learn.
There's your question is now answered.
You're welcome.
Now, I think I've covered all these silly corners now, huh?
Why would FUWAMOCO ever want to include you, Ruffians?
I don't get it.
I'll never understand.
You know, spending a bit more time with you today, I think you're just a boring and smelly lot.
Why they're so nice to you, but so rough to me, I don't get it.
But I guess this is just how things are, huh?
So, for their next dream!
Their next dream is this.
It's Phasmophobia.
I think they're going to be going ghost hunting with all the avagurlios, huh?
More intense training!
Now, Ruffians, you all know that it wasn't that good in the bathrooms the other day, huh?
That was all your fault.
Now you better lend them a very strong paw so they actually learn something.
And don't just cower in fear and depend on your avid members, okay?
Make sure you push them a bit, okay?
Yes, it's your fault.
Yes.
It's their fault, but it's also your fault.
You need to push them a bit more.
Got it?
And for the next stuff, like I said, there's the Splash Party, but there's also the Celebration!
Okay, you can't miss it!
The 500,000 Ruffians Celebration on YouTube!
And you know, they'll be singing some American wild songs too.
You know, Papa Puppy!
Papa Puppy and I, we go back quite a while.
So I wonder if they'll be howling any of those songs that we used to party together with.
Yeah, party!
I remember those times.
It'll be interesting, that's for sure.
Got it.
You're gonna be there for them, right?
Cause they're just there to protect your smile.
But you need new Ruffians.
You need to make sure to train them properly, okay?
I'm gonna be off a bit.
So I'm depending on you, okay?
Got it?
Now, I have to give you credit.
Thank you for joining me for the last episode of FUWAMOCO Morning for this week.
I guess this is a bit embarrassing, but I should probably do this too, huh?
Would you like it?
Now don't be too happy if I read out your name or anything, okay?
Okay?
You.
Good job today.
The Lamb.
Hi.
I see you.
Marcy.
Have a good day.
Next car.
You too.
Take easy.
Fino?
That's a pretty good name.
It's sort of similar to Pero.
Have a good day.
Ria.
You too.
Take easy.
And to every other Ruffian out there, have a good day.
Maybe not a howl of a day, but a good day.
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
With Pero.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Later, Ruffians!
Later.